it was plenty of warning before typhoon
hagupit arrived but the power of the
storm caught some of Japan's most
vulnerable by surprise intense rainfall
cut off many people and communities
including dozens of elderly in a
retirement home in calico air northwest
of the capital Tokyo after the storm
passed they were brought to safety by
rescue workers the storm brought
damaging winds in excess of 200
kilometers an hour but the main feature
was a huge amount of rainfall some areas
saw a meter in 24 hours and waterways
simply couldn't cope the embankments of
more than 20 rivers collapsed one of the
worst hit areas was Nagano Prefecture
west of Tokyo where a 70 meter stretch
of the levee gave way many homes and
businesses were flooded and Japan's
famous bullet trains were surrounded by
water and going nowhere fast or slow ma
tante who the major typhoon has caused
extensive damage far and wide in eastern
Japan at one point the special warning
for heavy rain was issued for as many as
13 prefectures there has also been
emergency release from various dams and
flooding of various rivers it turned out
to be a record heavy rain more than a
hundred thousand rescue workers were
deployed including 31,000 from the
self-defense forces millions were
ordered or advised to evacuate but some
chose not to leave their homes or
couldn't get out in time Japanese are
used to preparing for storms and other
natural disasters but this one was
different it may have come and gone
quickly but many here say it was the
largest most intense typhoon they've
experienced and they're wondering
because of climate change if it's a sign
of things to come
in some places a recovery has begun but
this was a storm that claimed many lives
and caused vast amounts of damage the
full extent of which won't be known for
some time with so many areas still
inundated Wayne hey al Jazeera Tokyo